I want to talk about Craigslist for a
second a lot of the people in our
audience use Craigslist it's important
to land well I want to help my audience
I thought I'd help audience members make
a sale or connection by showing some of
their craigslist ads right here on the
show right now I've obtained them first
up vacation rental romantic hideaway in
the heart of Hollywood I will be
watching from the closet
[Applause]
Brad Pitt look-alike seeking woman who's
never seen Brad Pitt
[Music]
domestic help wanted someone to tell me
where I put the damn horseradish I mean
for crying out loud it was just here
[Music]
for sale time machine that only travels
back to Seattle
[Music]
for sale crossbow that has been fired
once in a jealous rage what what's going
on here how about hiring new director
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry oh and I Love You Man but what
next one orange you glad you clicked on
my ad get it lol here we go
medical marijuana for sale must suffer
from some kind of disease like not being
high enough
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
saxophone player wanted not for a band
but to provide soundtrack will I walk
around my apartment smoking cigarettes
and reflecting on my various failure
finally caring loving man seeking woman
for committed relationship will also
settle for a crusty Eisen
[Music]
you